heavily uppercut take 19 good sound
effect yeah my boy Johnny Cage
hello and welcome to potato mode the
show where we take your favorite games
and turn them into mush I am John Luke
and I am joined by Ben how's it going
and we're taking a look today at Mortal
Kombat 11 we're gonna show you how good
this game can look and then we're gonna
see how hard we can push the settings
all the way down and then we're gonna
get weird with it so it's definitely
worth mentioning that via the PC version
of this game very pretty oh yeah there's
also some really cool stuff where a lot
of the the in fight scenes will actually
run at 60 frames instead of 30 I'm
pretty sure those are the counts it's
definitely an increased but overall just
a wonderful looking game really and I
can't wait just being how bad sit up
yeah just turn all that off blue motion
blur don't even know what it is lighting
huh don't make me laugh 720p is the
lowest you can go actually you know what
before we should probably quit sometimes
some changes don't actually apply but
you could just tell how uncomfortable
everyone in that class was without worry
that guys wallpapers were like there's
like once you get passed over using the
scale like the 1 to 10 scale like once
you get into like the like eights or
nines I start to wonder like maybe you
shouldn't do that I'm just over you're
talking about people's pornography that
they have on their phones I realize
already going whoa where'd the ground go
look at his hair No
Skynet beamed me either way Skynet needs
to take you back your room knows you
you're missing some pie you're not
something downloading yet it's alright
the textures just got to wake up it's
like a like an Unreal Engine 3 game yeah
I actually kind of like the low res
skeleton looks looks good and the metal
skeleton yeah I was about to be like oh
that looks weird and I forgot he's a
robot
but of course Ben we can
always get it even lower you betcha
why do we do that we're the Texaco
that's my favorite rule if I can't read
it it's not legal then I have to worry
about anything this means nothing to me
WB gotcha
the legal loophole we figured about all
all the texts from here on out I'm just
non-existent
should we let's just try going on a
match see what happens go on here we're
talking about the fact that the game
reads off the menu is a great
accessibility thing and where'd you go
so I love how that realization that
these are all JPEGs of a character yeah
did you see them like that's good which
one should I pick you still smooth who
do you want to see who do you want to
see move I wanna I want to see I go on
to see Johnny Cage I always want to see
Johnny Cage the Joker Oh nuts there's
there's something really disturbing
about all that outside of what about
Johnny Cage what about Johnny Cage he
looks good how the teeth are all red
like you no no thank you
I can't tell what moves I have on my
desk that's fine
everything just it's a good it's a good
kind of smooth oh not a chance
oh the round was uh yeah you can't tell
what the time is
oh yeah I have no idea what's the time
let's just read that the UH like the
blood texture still gathers up on the
ground to not expected that's not to
kind of just disappear and not exist
anymore I mean that's the core part of
the Mortal Kombat feature it really is
and if it'll blow on me come on it'll
blow me yeah you definitely see that
it's cuz I put on easy dude itches not
fatal blow you uneasy that is setting
maybe oh that works definitely works
I'd like to do story mode
thank you I want to see what the
cutscenes look like yeah here we go
wow wow yeah the blood still looks
really good it looks almost like huge to
be honest
anyway good fight mom ah dang they're
all pre-rendered honest a bummer
although it is a pretty good testament
to how well put together they are where
we thought they were an inch it looks
like these people just got dipped into
like like that ended cherry like candy
hard shell do you get it like a shop or
like oh I got like a melted crayons mm
some wax yeah all right let's go to uh
let's go to someone dumb Oh why would
you do this we have to look at him close
up he's gonna move in like wink at us oh
look at this menu there's gonna be a
little difficult to navigate here
no I don't wanna know I'm gonna close
the preview window I'm gonna let you do
this by yourself look at all these
hairstyles we can pick them oh I don't
like it
jeez the explosion oh I hope the spray
paints just yep that's what I'm looking
for
never jacquard it's like I've made art
it's beautiful no uh no thank you come
now notice that's a thumbnail and a half
oh here we go get a good shot of that
exoskeleton just looks exactly like it
the exact same
actually getting kind of a better shot
of how the skin just disappears pretty
good you can't even see
no wonder Kim can't flip it get higher
on a tier list cuz you just can't see oh
that's pretty cool legging
yeah right I'm into that oh I like his
eyes too with the the green smoke coming
off of him yeah oh that's actually
that's actually really cool like I'm way
into that I come at you with my green
squares prepared whoa Oh his hairs gone
too we crashed the game yeah that
crashed the game hoo boy
well Ben I think what we're all really
here to see are some fatalities heck
yeah
oh no that kool-aid mm-hmm yeah right it
I look it looks kind of like it might
taste good it looks like inside of a
gusher it the risk of sounding
disgusting I'll say it I'll jump on it I
would drink it this literally was like a
like a gusher at that point
good sound effect yeah my boy Johnny
Cage oh it's more shiny than it should
be put that blue brain though I would I
would eat that it's the gusher I'm tired
of it I would eat that
yeah oh never mind that was one of my
favorites oh look at all that gusher
juice
oh yeah ok nevermind it's still nasty
should I be the puke even more gross I
don't want to eat this one oh I'm not
looking forward to this welcome to
devorah's unboxing videos where we unbox
gushers live for you here
oh no oh you can't see that each it
changed a fatality dose of it the whole
point of it is God
[Laughter]
it's so simple but it's so elegant oh
the goop looks pretty good yeah nice and
goofy yeah yeah Oh Jax why no you got to
hand it to him yeah all the school
well the gusher inside it's perfect
oh I don't like it all the insides
that's like a peanut butter center oh
why does it say no butter no potato mo
turns everything into food ah I don't
know if peanut butter and gushy shoes
really go well together thanks for
watching everybody this episode of
potato mode but don't worry we are gonna
be back because in a few weeks the
aftermath expansion is coming out so we
got more things in this game to potato
Phi including Robo Cop which I'm kind of
curious how that's gonna play out you're
very excited to see him uh yeah and if
there are any like things that we did
like fatalities that we didn't get to
cover in this that are some of your
favorites so you want to be potato fide
let us know and maybe we'll find some
time to get those in in the next episode
thanks for watching guys
[Music]